welcome to Simply learn if you haven't  subscribed yet hit the Subscribe button  below and let's start learning about  cyber security in one minute  with 4.9 billion people using the  internet in 2022 cyber security now has  to protect users against ranges like  viruses malware adware and other  ransomware attacks  it involves techniques that help secure  various digital components like networks  data and computer systems from  unauthorized access the financial impact  of these security breaches is massive be  it for an Enterprise environment or for  personal computers deploying firewalls  using web protection suits and stronger  encryption are just a few ways to  bolster your network security even job  rules in cyber security Now range from  ethical hacking to security analysts in  big forms providing ample growth  opportunities to pne1 starting out in  the cyber security domain  [Music]